citizens of the reject Nation we are
here to watch She-Hulk episode hopefully
Daredevils in
and if he's not it'll be fine hopefully
it's a long subtitle yeah this is a
crazy title today ladies and gentlemen
uh please go ahead and leave a like
that'd be extremely appreciate Hulk
smash that like button follow koi
chandro over on Tick Tock where he's
tick-tocking all the time with 15 second
30 second to three minute videos now 10
you should do 10 minute video 10 minute
videos 45 minutes just to talk that's
John a documentary hi guys I don't I
make these videos John makes all the
videos
guys both of you about Daredevil
here's my opinion hey I want to thank
everyone who's bought a shirt from uh
shopzeroedition.com uh your support
means a lot it's one of the best ways to
support the channel so thank you very
much and uh the team of prepper thank
you for helping us down these highlights
all right let's get into it
Josh
plan was to strike up a very normal
conversation with a beautiful woman
that dance I don't trust it this recap
kind of gave it away yeah
and we we thought so I I oh yeah I was
like maybe not but no the way they've
the way they put they've framed that in
this whole thing yeah hey there's like
two things that matter here Blonsky in
this creep
interesting shot
very ominous
oh Little Miss Marvel text action
oh she's happy
dude what a lovely parasol
oh nice
there's style to the transitions here
someone had fun directing this one
and I don't trust him damn it man oh no
he's too good 201 can't trust him he
just took her blood right there that's
it
oh you can't get away with that kind of
language on Disney Plus
without that emoji means
kind of wanting to be a bad guy but he's
so obviously is oh
I like how this is all like visual yeah
yeah tone
nicely done Jen
some good love montages in the MCU
lately yeah Heroes need love true that
great definition or triceps
good work
don't sexualize dealt two
hey
did it with her as Jen
oh purple
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
he went to F boy Island and they never
speak again it's just the first 12 hours
after you slept with someone for the
first time it's just gonna feel icky you
just gotta Coast through it without
doing anything stupid I text right away
what are you doing from the Next Room
could be in a meeting or at the movies
there's weddings funerals job interviews
silent Retreats I hope he's at all of
those today
oh
oh no maybe Josh wasn't evil but the
evil people are doing something evil to
Josh they're putting the large Angel in
Josh no
[Music]
no there's some wonderful composition to
the shot
every frame of painting
I want to go that painting every frame a
collage
what a malfunction alert on
Huskies inhibitor
did he turn into the Abomination we
don't know
I gotta go up to that Wackadoo Ranch of
Hayes
I'm not interrupting your weekend plans
am I
no no not at all nope I will see you
there oh that's great because the whole
place is full of weirdos
oh we're gonna get cameos Ghost Rider's
gonna be here
Ghost Rider confirmed all the
thunderbolt's first appearance they're
coming at the ranch I think the X-Men
are going to be the range
Wolverine and Deadpool are gonna be
there confirmed Deadpool 3 takes place
at the ranch
[Music]
[Laughter]
I love this episode so much this is so
Punchy so maybe put on your your green
suit
put on my greens here yeah get big jolly
green yourself I don't know what that's
not how it works whatever then would you
please
it's definitely not functioning
I don't know why hey do you think maybe
you might have jostled it or
it was worth it because my favorite
chicken
princess silk feather was stuck your
favorite chicken yeah
pepper chicken great well I have
recalibrated your inhibitor so stay away
from the electric fence maybe then I
won't have to make any more scary trips
up here not that I don't I don't like
coming up here I just yeah come back
anytime
it's always in such a hurry to leave
well he did think he was coming out here
to face the Abomination
now what about you then Jeff
um I thought you worked really hard to
get out of prison and that you'd be
really dumb to go back there all right
so I'm gonna get moving
oh no whoa dang it was
what the hell
wait
what was that ah memble I mean I
certainly CD list sorry sorry that's my
fault you know what apologize to my
Prius Prime with money I absolutely
apologize to your Prius if that'll make
you feel better
brother vlantis actually taught me a lot
about taking responsibility for my anger
man bull yeah and I am
no idea
got nothing
every person who's trying to you know
stab him in the you know for being a an
affront to nature of which there are
many so many yeah
so much unnecessary backstory to tell to
someone whose car you just destroyed
remember
give us a push to the garage would you
do I look like a mechanic my name is Van
bull not mechanical bull nicely done tow
truck won't get here until later today
having a fantastic news Well it means
that you can spend some time here you
know relax I believe Manville first
fought Daredevil
yeah he's gonna he's gonna come back to
take up that that lost mantle that fight
so if you could get me a desk and some
Wi-Fi
it's a bit of a hard ask distractions
from the outside and all that oh and you
have no reception anywhere either
maybe it's how you need to spend your
day
[Music]
clearly you're not in a teachable mood
right now
I was just wondering what happened to
the cool style of the show
[Music]
laughs
if you transform a She-Hulk you can run
further and then that's much closer to
the satellites yeah at least a foot and
a half
oh no way is that porcupine was that
porcupine
uh this is porcupine
saracen thinks he's a vampire wow this
is quite a group thinks he's a vampire
last session we really explored
Alejandro's struggles with his identity
just because I am Spanish and I have a
flair for the style people constantly
it's dehumanizing Spanish is a language
not a nationality so you've never heard
of Spain
awesome
have been spending a lot of time
together I'm feeling like maybe it's
not healthy unhealthy I know what I call
that too I'm sorry porcupine I'm gonna
share something
remember
[Music]
that I need on a t-shirt
God damn sorry I'm late I I lost track
of time in the yurt no way Jen I really
needed it though I was hurting for a
year that guy's here you probably don't
even remember who he is tell me they
previously owned him no I don't care
previously on this guy that's further a
wrecking curve yeah yeah showing off
your powers you better be able to back
it up oh hey
this [ __ ] and his friends attacked me
behind my apartment I'm gonna need you
to sit in the calming chair right now
right now
and so I realized real strength comes
from facing yourself in the mirror and
saying hey man
I'm gonna work on me
I didn't need a magic crowbar to give me
a false sense of power so he's a wrecker
yeah must be oh you attacked a woman
four to one you absolutely were super
villains I hear you Jen and I take
radical accountability
I met a guy we went on a few dates and I
thought it was going great and then I
haven't heard from him when's the last
time you talked to him uh three nights
ago when we when we slept together for
the first time another direct heat
what was the last thing you texted
um that was fun I can't stop smiling
yikes I can't stop smiling it is thirsty
and a cliche you're sir standing cliche
well just now because I was so worried I
hadn't heard from him in so long for all
I knew he was in a ditch somewhere what
did you do what did you do hey
getting a little worried just want to
know you're okay blushing smile
[Laughter]
uh
I think that we have to start
considering the very real possibility
that you were ghosted or he wanted your
blood no not that
some vampire
but he's dropping an actual clue Chen is
great no one cares when they're She-Hulk
so like I meet this guy who actually
likes Jen and that just felt good to
know that you know and then he ghosts me
and it sucks oh all right screw this guy
where does he live let's go that's right
he's Gotta Die oh big men please no man
boot is correct Josh has made an enemy
of this entire group
[Laughter]
you've been warned about using
bioelectricity in group before so let's
go find this Josh guy and suck out all
his blood
I'd say you can't control what other
people do
it hurts when someone rejects us
because it reminds us of the times
goes out
[Laughter]
there's a group of guys right here who
would love to spend time with Jen right
now
okay Jen do you believe that this group
genuinely values the whole of you
genuinely yeah I do and there it is so
maybe you can stop using She-Hulk as a
protective shield
and trust us
with gem
I don't trust that record there visiting
Abomination
seems sketchy sketchy like this whole
SNL sketch we just watched on the
machine
yeah that was a sketchum this is like an
emotional chord scene
I just porcupine being here makes it
worth it for me
oh
do it for us
[Music]
it smells like a fart too much oh no
if Josh isn't spending time on Jen then
Jen doesn't need to be spending time on
Josh delete Josh's numbers what he's
saying
[Applause]
how do you feel
I can't believe I'm gonna say this but
I'm hurting for a year
[Music]
the show is in California
I like The Stranger Things music yeah
it's like happy stranger things
look at that supportive men in the show
yeah see good men in a sketch feel free
to come again oh not till you get Wi-Fi
foreign
I guess Emile blonski really is just
this guy now just good not a thunderbolt
as we learned in d23
Josh is a bad guy because he ghosted and
Blonsky not a bad guy Obama stay Obama
stay today is today
[Music]
he did get her blood damn you jump
[Music]
not a good guy that phone was copying
the data hmm they showed us subtly
well-written program oh no
oh
ick
no hope King ah
props down to volume that recap made it
way too low yeah
they perhaps should not have spoon fed
us the evil Josh plot line it's one
thing disrespected it's another thing to
be like yeah it also wasn't like the
beginning of the Season it was like the
last episode it wasn't like we'd
forgotten Josh we just met Josh we're
excited to see that pay off yeah
remember this guy from five minutes ago
well he's evil remember him and remember
the Big Bad Evil
same show that gives us Frogman gives us
porcupine
matadorian
junior varsity my man
hurting for a yearton porcupine's one of
my favorite sporting characters and
Jessica Drew uh Spider Woman and one day
one day yeah get that laundry done dude
go to Luke Anderson that's saracen
characters sounds so familiar well we
got more vampires in the MCU day by day
vks related to like a street level hero
or connected to Something tells them
there's not a post credit scene you'll
never know something tells me
that it's not going to be a post credit
Georgia let's see it
yeah we got what we wanted the Georgia
Line
with that post credit scene about
Georgia it's funny you know if there's
something that just does subconsciously
to your brain that if they place that
Josh moment after the credits
I got some opinions about this episode
let's talk about it alrighty well
that was an episode
it was all right it's gonna I'm on a I'm
Gonna Roll here with the unpopular
opinions he swings too he swings bro he
swings two
I wrote I know last week I was like I
can tell people I'm really gonna like
this episode I thought it was a lot of
fun and and then this one in particular
it was an interesting Journey because in
the first few minutes before you know
they go to the Abominations Camp uh I I
was like okay this might actually be one
of the most uh purposeful stylistic
choices and there's such a great grip on
the tonality of what they're capturing
here like we don't have time to like go
into the whole backstory of Josh you get
all this dialogue so let's just show
their romance Brewing through the visual
language and I thought it was really
well done and like you reference or one
of you guys it Miss Marvel when they
were doing their stylistic choices which
references Scott Pilgrim versus the
world so they were there they had a good
grasp on all that and then around the
time they they show up at Emile
blonsky's place
you see you guys got to understand
something if you're watching this on
YouTube versus patreon.com that's the
real rejects you are watching reaction
highlights so what you guys probably saw
was the moments where all of us really
enjoyed some of that stuff with everyone
it's the way it's cut up because it's
reaction highlights and so we're cutting
around that where but though uh I'll be
honest like it progressively got
annoying to me and and it was it really
felt like a a bad parody it felt like
when you know SNL does a sketch of like
the Avengers and it it didn't feel like
I didn't care for any of the chemistry
with anyone none of them sound like real
characters that all sounded like bad
comedy writing to me like just straight
up bad comedy writing with a with a
random
albeit great performed monologue uh from
Jen and somehow by placing it in this
episode
weirdly that monologue was not feeling
earned to me so as great of a
performance as it was I wasn't as
connected to it as I was really craving
to be craving as I was craving to be
connected yeah
man imagine him in that session they
would have just uh this is they should
reference some of the people there
because yeah we confirmed it mamble man
bull Daredevil Daredevil excellent pole
man I I have not thought of man I've
heard I've heard I've heard a bunch of
rumors of people who might appear in
this show all of them have come true so
far all those thing episodes and man
bull was one of those things if I
remember Jason
[Laughter]
[Music]
was one of the things I remember
learning about Daredevils
storm so yeah I I didn't and also
um the Emile Blonsky thing seemed to I
get the choice you know that someone
might change after several years in
prison or however long he's been there
be reformed I get it and there was
something about that felt more enjoyable
to me when you had a sneaking suspicion
that there might be something like false
about what he's doing and the way he's
presenting himself that's what made it
fun
and then for me in this episode when
you're like oh it's genuine okay let me
roll with this I'm like this is not fun
anymore for some reason and somehow I
feel like you're robbing us of
abomination and a great character
although they did show in the trailers
that there's supposed to be another
moment where he is abomination but if
it's just going to be some joke like
this to me started feeling like the
thing I've heard people complain about
of where you are making it because this
wasn't like you know how people
sometimes defend this show but like guys
you'll get it just like a sitcom show
you know like this didn't feel like that
to me this felt like a bad parody and
with a random a couple of heartfelt
moments so yeah uh this was uh this is
this is probably the one I like the
least out of every episode we've seen so
far
um
but that's just my opinion
koi roll the dice I uh you know I felt
like this episode was a this isn't for
me episode and I I've really been
looking at the enjoyment of you know the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as we go into
phase four and it's been really
interesting comparing it to other phases
where I was like oh this is all for me
not everything in phase four has been
for me and I've I think I've made myself
enjoy things in a different way where I
was like oh I don't usually like sitcoms
maybe this is a gateway to sitcoms and
some of the episodes work in that vein
and some of them don't this one did not
quite work for me uh I found myself like
wanting to laugh and then having that
Hollow moment of like where I'm like oh
no that's not a laugh that's me trying
to use my diaphragm again and it just
didn't feel like I was experiencing
humor it felt like I was trying to
experience humor and that's not to say
it's in any one thing the writing
directing the acting certainly not the
acting it's a toned thing so I get why
choices were made I understand stand
what the goals were but it felt like
okay I can understand the choices and
the goals but it doesn't mean they
worked so I kept seeing a lot of pole
vaulting and no Landing
um I love porcupine one of my favorite
characters in the modern comic era
because he's so sweet and endearing and
he so the arc I love with porcupine is
in um Jessica Drew Spider Woman it is
two arcs ago roughly 2016-2017
Spider-Woman comic she's a single mom
and uh I I my mom raised me as a as a
teen mom and it it means the world to me
to see strong women superheroes
sometimes have kids and like that's a
very specific tukoi thing so this run on
Jessica Drew means a lot to me and
porcupine comes in and he basically
starts babysitting her child out of the
kindness of his heart and then they grow
to have a romance together and it's out
of the authentic sweetness of the
character trust me this makes sense and
is worth this rant about a comic
character and all of these things make
you care about porcupine more and more
even though he's been a c villain even
though he doesn't have the direct
chemistry of Jessica Drew even though
Jessica Drew has been duplicitous her
whole life her parents are spy she has a
lot of messy backstory she was a scroll
all of the things endear you to him more
because of his open heart that can't
exist with this version of the character
because now we've met him as a simpleton
that felt like it was joking at
porcupine not with porcupine I want to
laugh with porcupine not at porcupine
and now the character that I really
appreciate can't really be used in that
way and I feel like that about
everything in this Dynamic a lot of
these these generalities undermine the
Integrity of characters that are even
aware of their ridiculousness yeah like
I don't even really know these
characters like they were used as a a
punch line but they're not all like you
I me you immediately get the sense that
even if you don't know these characters
that this feels like a parody of them
right yeah
like the kind of dialogue they were
given them is like when you pluck a
popular character and you you give them
like this relatable hey girl
it felt like a Prius commercial not only
because they said Prius Prime but uh
also because it felt like one of those
shots where you have this really
well-lit room there's a lot of things
that are funny in a circle and like that
felt it had moments of of pure sketch
yeah
this is an interesting episode to me
partly because I think yeah the
conversation surrounding comedy and how
it relates to the MCU is quite
interesting because
if you're trying to reflect Comics yeah
I get the characters go through
different iterations and are presented
in different ways depending on who's
writing them and all that stuff and I
feel like this show kind of I can feel
that under a microscope with this show
and I wonder if we get more things like
this if we'll feel more natural in
retrospect but this was an episode that
I'm kind of I'm torn on because I
largely found the experience of watching
it relatively Charming but it felt more
like a comic strip or or something more
slight I guess and yeah you start off
with this really Dynamic opening
sequence a lot of visual storytelling a
lot of stuff that relies on you know
just like filmmaking Rhythm and energy
and snap and then you get part way into
the episode and then you and I don't
even begrudge at this uh structurally
you you remove yourself from our main
World by going out to this compound and
then the whole Pace changes and yeah you
get a lot of goofy jokey stuff and it
made me think about last week because Mr
Immortal
um you know I feel like that's an
example perhaps not that I know the
backstory of the character but a genius
way to yeah but I think so it felt like
a character you you yeah
so consistently came back I was like yes
yeah and you meet that character and
that character is obviously very quirky
heightened and a bit ridiculous but has
such a clear perspective of his own that
even when he's clashing with the room
you can tell no no that's how this
character is this character is very well
defined and well drawn and yeah here I
felt like they gave each it was like I
was in an improv show and every yeah a
character ten minutes to back research
backstory and then it was kind of like
watching the show that he touched at the
UCB the the you know oh yeah like
whatever that yeah character's squaring
off trying to have nerds tournaments it
kind of felt like that and uh and yeah
so it's like way funnier than this
sure and I mean I think they derive an
interesting for me they derived a
semi-interesting blend of okay I I guess
I don't quite believe that all these
things are as innocuous as they seem and
thus that's creating a certain tension
but I guess the further we get the more
I'm just like well like you said okay I
guess a meal just is this guy now which
to me I think is charming because he is
so Charming at it Tim Roth was always
Charming even though I didn't always
love what it was happening to have him
be Charming I was like Tim Ross crushing
this yeah and I feel like you could make
use of that moving forward and and you
could even I feel like my problems are
less with his Maneuvers and how that was
written and blah blah blah and how that
was performed then it was more with
everyone around them yeah feeling more
like hey let's just grab some mad cat
characters from the DNC list and just
kind of throw them in there and oh yeah
this made me more excited for Jen
Walters in Captain America New World
Order which is the rumor this made me
more excited to see her in other things
because I kept being like wow Charming
funny stunning awesome like I kept
having those moments with She-Hulk but I
didn't enjoy the show episode enough
that I was like it made me want more
She-Hulk as I've experienced but not
more of this
I feel like they had I feel like they
had enough time it's like I think what
you said is also a very sharp because I
was like in a better episode I would
feel more emotional about Jen's little
breakthrough and I feel like they had
enough time in this episode to really
sell that with actual character beats
that might have been humorous rather
than doing what feels like taking a lot
of time to do bits basically and then
spending a lot of the time on that it's
like you can feel the plot but then the
character Journey feels very thin and
very comic strip because of that yeah
one note cork jokes about everyone I get
it yeah he thinks he's a vampire we
should use that three times
it felt like they kept going yeah I
think there's a lack of I think overall
with the way this show has been because
there were seven episodes and and there
is a quality to this show that does feel
like there's a bit of a lack of focus as
much as I've been having fun with it
like I've I feel like the three of us
have enjoyed this
shows like a lot of people yeah YouTube
comments they're full of enjoyment from
all so when I I mean yeah when I when I
was watching this and then when she did
get to that speech
I it did have me going I feel like
throughout these six episodes we really
haven't explored this struggle that
she's had because this is so heavy the
way she's delivering this and I feel
like this show hasn't done that great of
a job it's like there are moments you
can pinpoint to it it's more of an
emotional association with the way these
scenes have been delivered and the aura
of these of the emotional struggle
because I've always picked up on it I've
we've talked extensively about like what
she's going through underneath the
surface but yet the weight of that
hasn't really been spread out in a way
that allows that scene to land of oh
she's finally making that breakthrough
because I was like I feel like we were
just still building that [ __ ] up I
didn't think we're going to switch over
I didn't think we were already at this
point where she was like dude wouldn't
people like about like it seemed like we
were so there and I didn't really feel
like we dealt enough with the struggle
other than you know they've you it's
like yes I I know you can pinpoint the
things of like yeah she got the career
through She-Hulk um the the guy who
slept with her who she was really into
slept with She-Hulk instead of her I
still and then the thing they do with
Jen often seems to be like people Treat
Her Like She's a a nuisance randomly
which doesn't really make sense because
she's so like it's the one I mean you
see this joke everywhere but like the
most unbelievable bit of writing for
shield because that no one would fall in
love with Tatiana yes like what a
staggeringly perfect woman that's the
problem I I have with that monologue of
like getting to this point in the show
is they've done such a good job at
showing that one side of like yeah
people kind of prefer to like spend time
with She-Hulk yet they're parts of Jen
that I'm like but what is I don't see
enough of Jen struggling as as Jen
rather than some real quick
cliche stuff and usually fairly quickly
solved like using stuff is like all
right by the end of the episode that out
22 minutes I will say though I like
positives whoever's training Tatiana
maslani and the work she's putting in
she has such incredible definition
to have that dealt with tricep combo and
the obliques and the leanness and the
way she doesn't look bulky the
athleticism is just spectacular
I love how
we gotta talk positives
first to go it's go let me tell you how
hot that woman's body is
she's put in the work you could tell a
lot of effort a lot of hustle a lot of
work a lot of diet restriction it's very
hard to look that lean good job Tatiana
yeah she's in Greece great that's my
positive this is so this also did give
me an interesting Pang because we spend
a lot of time in the group circle and
part of me half my brain went I wish we
would spend this much time in any of
those courtroom scenes and then be when
you said that I was immediately like God
damn he's right because it is like way
more at least immersed in that but also
they have a great opportunity with
Wreckers showing up to actually confront
something that's real and that's like
kind of difficult in actual life which
is like oh hey this is actually like a
person who's directly attacked me and
now they're trying to reform and now I'm
being asked to like be sympathetic
towards them that's a like a big
conversation that I think you could
handle both humorously and seriously and
I feel like that's something that in the
spirit of the show with it's plugged in
as they seem to want to be about uh just
the day and age the show exists in the
kind of cultural debates we have
especially surrounding uh you know like
the treatment of women and stuff like
that I feel like that was an opportunity
they didn't catch as well as they could
have because it's Charming again as I
found that odd character turn and the
weird suspicion that it kind of guides
you on that Journey with at the same
time I was like ah yeah I wish you would
take these opportunities even though
this is a sitcom to like
and you don't have to do a very special
episode but like actually do do the meat
of that because then that will also
bolster tangentially you know the whole
gen She-Hulk you know mixture storyline
anyway the emotionality of that I know
there's a slant that comes with the word
sitcom as if that means like uh just
stupid jokes but there's been some great
sitcoms out there where there are very
fleshed out characters and I think they
could have had that moment the moments
with those characters not be just the oh
yeah I thought that was really yeah I
was like oh no show what are you doing
it's bad because it's a better bad
schedule right like the whole the second
man bull showed up and I was like oh I
kind of recognized someone yeah good
good for you crazy
first appearance though come on a man
bull I think it's better to to surprise
and it can be more funny I think to
surprise yeah with an actual moment of
vulnerability or a character beat than
just a joke that therapy that not
therapy thing but the because yeah they
make a mockery of of a meal first off
yeah it felt like laughing out now with
again and that's kind of my thing in
porcupine it didn't feel like we were
laughing with which
I am upset about can you not feel my
range
he's all soft inside he may be spiky on
the outside but inside he's all goo
hashtag not koi's Porky not my porcupine
I thought that whole thing could have
had heart sure
yeah lacked heart that's what I wanted
from that whole dynamic that and that
and we felt that a few times like when
we have negatives about this show it's
the lack of seriousness and it's not
like Marvel doesn't know like obviously
it's everyone's different creative team
but it's not like they don't know how to
balance comedy and drama typically and
yes this is a different tone but as
you're saying sitcoms don't mean thin
they just mean situational comedy these
are situations where in there can be
comedy
that's what you'd like well Kevin foggy
spread too thin and Blade's only 90
minutes I know is that the thing saracen
is the reason the director everyone was
yelling about blade and I was like I've
been busy at Disneyland yeah what
happened did you see blade what do you
mean 90 minutes like you got it that's
our best friend Jeff Snyder yep he broke
okay and then it got everywhere
it's all over all over the interwebs yep
that blade is our video on blade right
now in real time tell me in real double
whammy here's my reaction well I mean it
was like blade director is Gonna Leave
satisfied yeah and then sure enough a
little bit later it was announced blade
left great director left
and that the movie is only 90 minutes
and that there's only two action scenes
and then rehearsal leaves upset
and it was like all over Twitter and I
was like oh okay well maybe they can fix
it
this is my response to it Kevin will
spread himself this way to fix the other
thing going around is like Kevin foggy
is is apparently Spread Way Too Thin
right now whoa I feel like a pizza dough
inevitable I feel like that's a foregone
conclusion that's crazy you can't be
Kevin feige enough to spread every
direction you can't but also 90 minute
blade and upset rehearsala and the
director quitting this deep in the game
that's why we've had three sets of
Marvel announcements no blade I mean it
might have been uh it must be I mean
it's like that information came out and
then a little bit later Hollywood
Reporter reported that the director left
and I was like okay
dude all they have to do is add 15 more
minutes of action and it'll be great if
you guys think we're spoiling something
I'm like what do we spoiling a movie
that may have a possible run time and a
couple of only two years like we didn't
spoil anything about it
they might reshoot the whole thing the
movie is about mahershal ali trying to
make the movie longer I don't think it's
shot
you don't think I don't think they shot
it yet how is it 90 minutes if it's your
script is the script oh it's like 91
pages and they're like that's about 90
minutes
where's my movie I quit every page
fascinating yeah I'm like mer Herschel
is one of the best working like if he
that's that's a mess
well
Marvel's over guys that's it the canary
is blade it's been a pleasure
probably made a bunch of jokes great
delts though great tracks
excellent
it's just a dedication man she put in
the work that's just that's not easy to
do I think that's every Marvel lead
actor yeah but you I don't know if you
don't fawn over Paul Rudd when he gets
back you haven't seen my reaction video
It's Just You breaking down all this
different muscle I mean that'd be
because it's a foregone conclusion that
you got to get in shape that it
shouldn't be credited this is hard work
we work hard well I mean it is a
different type of I mean I'll work as
hard as these guys or you uh but uh
Tatiana must I just suddenly felt really
fat and I felt my stomach bloated
the mighty just Morphin Power Rangers
Morphin time yeah but yeah that was that
was an episode all right it was all
right we're done we're done now
considering we talked about blade and
Fitness
every episode can be saved by an
appearance by Punk guys I know that
Deadpool 3 was confirmed with Hugh
Jackman this week so the lack of
Deadpool Cameo is disheartening I would
have expected better from Marvel why
didn't you give me a Deadpool Cameo of
the week that they confirmed it why
didn't you do that for me this well I'll
leave with this too because yes you're
all right about that they did porcupine
dirty that's what they did
take a drink
what I I I'm not gonna jump the shark
yet and say I'm worried about how
they're gonna handle Daredevil because
something tells me that they're going to
be so aware yeah that they have
Daredevil but they gotta make it the
best it could be yeah granted I wasn't a
fan of Hawkeye when it came to Kingpin
so I am a bit nervous
I have seen a scene with Daredevil that
was exceptional but three minutes when
you're in a room at d23 with a giant
crowd that was exceptional but I don't
know what it's going to be the overall
tone and when they're cheering the whole
time you can't hear a
wordliners
some sort of Man Without Fear she's
doing like Will Smith who just says
catchphrases like this is excellent I'm
to a point now where I feel like any the
writers and directors who are involved
obviously have a say but I feel like
just any time Charlie Cox is Matt
Murdock he will Bridge some of that Gap
yeah he just demands it of it like yeah
just like [ __ ] Ryan Ryan was like I
could do d23 or I could just do it in my
goddamn self like I love that Ryan
Reynolds is like two weeks after d23
I've been outshine every announcement
ever as Deadpool with Hugh Jackman
walking behind me well that is the
lowest like it's just so it's the lowest
Stakes highest rewards there's a big mic
truck I mean I I wonder if this is
turning into a random podcast I do I do
Wonder with what you said if like
maybe there was some consideration into
the fact of how much that would
overshadow everything because it's like
how do you win with these conventions
also he's responsible for not just a Gin
Company not just a phone company but
he's got a marketing company and I think
that he wanted to control it completely
yeah because you don't control the
narrative at d23 yeah because then you
can do the two videos like he did
exactly at the same time like of not
showing up at d23
you know I think that allowed people to
get excited for werewolf by night even
though even though there's a big like
you know
um commentary around the internet that
like d23 was let down that one trailer
was such a moment it gave people the
time to get really interested in weather
World War one that looks pretty cool
yeah yeah that's good and uh the Boost
so yeah I mean if that happened no one
would care about any other stuff right
nobody talked about we've been talking
about it right now like we are
love that Cameo from Deadpool
remember the shoes so good so good
Deadpool By Night Deadpool By Night
Crush very excited about it Deadpool
love and thunder is good you know
there's Deadpool and lashes and 10 Rings
there's there remember that time when
coach also post credits
from Jay Leno from The Tonight Show yeah
and then when he started coming back you
could feel like there was a bit of
Darkness I love that and I'm like
sometimes that comes out of YouTube
it's a really nice guy like a sweetheart
but that that nice Boston Irish guy
some dark resentments I really like the
idea of being TBS Conan yeah you bring
it internet let's [ __ ] dance
eventually Conor came back to be you
know more grounded and you know like it
just eventually yeah you know there was
that period where yeah
it's a [ __ ] money yeah if you want me
to get happy again Marvel you got my
number all right guys
we're really done now post credit
scene's been a long time bye everyone go
it's a Deadpool reference
[Music]
God I just got it
[Music]